[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est que ce billet je
n'aurais jamais dû accepter ce contrat
mais comment ça fait je ne sais pas dire
non je dis mais oui mais c'est simple de
dire non quand il faut y aller faut y
aller
inspiration décontraction sa vie
et y en a du monde ça change de
trouville sur mer
[Musique]
c'est applaudi mon public froid
tout d'abord avant de commencer ce
concert je voudrais remercier la
municipalité pour le prêt de safar ainsi
que le maire adjoint chargé de la
culture pour la remise en route du
chauffage dès 16 heures une heure de
récital sur le thème les oiseaux sur une
musique de niche à laon j'ai les mains
moites
non ça va y tient
[Musique]
e
en pinaillant pensées vagabondent dany
challans par toi non posées sont comme
des oiseaux elle s'envole un instant
s'arrête puis reparte dans une autre
direction
pensées vagabondes
je le sens pas ce concert respiration
décontraction cheville
[Musique]
n'empêche que c'est bon
la chance j'ai trouvé ça par hasard sur
internet j'ai cliqué sur un perron
imprimés et voilà tout mon programme de
concerts en un clic et ça l'air de
plaire
finalement tout se passe bien
respiration des contractions
cb
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais ce passage là je voulais jouer
trois mois
[Musique]
c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai si c'est
vrai c'est pas ça
[Musique]
mais je vais jamais réussir à tenir une
heure de récitals avec une seule page
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que cette famille
sanaa privé crée trois premières lignes
[Musique]
je me sens pas bien en baby dior
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est plus d'encre nonce tâche deux
pages 3 pascal pas s'en est pas si ce
saw vi
qu'est ce qu'il fout là
[Musique]
enfin l'essentiel c'est de les avoir
retrouvés
[Musique]
respiration décontraction
enfin le public a l'air de se rendre
compte de rien ça dort
[Musique]
c'est peut-être parce que j'ai pris trop
long je vais accélérer
[Musique]
ça me donne envie de chanter
oh je vois tous les enfants dans le sol
soit au tivoli key son boulot qu est ce
qui prend inspiration expiration
[Musique]
inspiration à expiration
en respiration
[Musique]
respiration
les
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette odeur
j'ai marché dans la crotte
[Musique]
ça l'odeur nauséabonde à chaque
changement d'hôpital ça fait ressortir
l'auteur de l'horreur
[Musique]
c'est ça il faut que je respire par la
bouche
fausse façon roshia qui tire sur sa
laisse
[Musique]
alors la consigne c'est de ne pas sortir
du du cercle rouge
ouais non parce qu'il est comme ça pour
la suite j'ai ça ça doit plus bon
l'oiseau on en a plus besoin vire
alors voilà c'est christian son fils
bonduelle adriano dieu
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup sophie
pasqua
dante aide via le e je vous disais
d'entertainment merci à toi de nous
avoir fait vivre ce langage de la
musique et de l'enterrement aussi une
petite question comment comment quand on
gagne on a une formation classique plus
une harpe qui est un instrument plutôt
très sérieux comment est-ce qu'on passe
de l'art formation classique à créer des
spectacles humoristiques et bien en fait
ma carrière était toute tracée
je devais faire de l'enseignement
donc j'avais un petit post et je me suis
dit pour bien ficeler mon petit poste
d'enseignement avec les petits élèves
je vais passer le certificat d'aptitude
à l'enseignement
c'est le truc mais alors là comme ça
ainsi il ya une jeune petit thouars peas
qui arrive je voudrais la place elle ne
peut pas la prendre
donc j'ai travaillé pendant trois ans
traits d'une façon très acharné marque
parce qu'évidemment fort prouver qu'on
sait jouer donc on a dû passer tous des
trucs des morceaux que les choses les
plus dures et bien là en fait ils n'ont
pas voulu de moi un bon donc du coup
quand j'ai eu les résultats
j'ai dit mais attendez regardez bien
bonduelle si en début de liste si quand
même pas dur à trouver
et ben non il m'a dit mais excusez moi
mais vous n'avez pas sur la liste
comment ça je suis pas sur la liste
alors là j'ai eu une fièvre terrible
plus de 40 de fièvre pendant une semaine
je me suis réveillé je me suis dit
j'arrête enseignement est alors la main
de rencontre en rencontre
après cet échec quand même assez
catastrophique
eh bien j'ai eu l'idée de raconter la
vie d'une artiste
ces stress son bonheur sa poésie et
voilà je me suis mis à écrire un
spectacle s'appelle sophie la harpiste
que je joue depuis presque vingt ans je
vais bientôt fêter mes 20 ans et si tu
avais un message à nous laisser si tu
voulais nous transmettre quelque chose
dans la vie donc que tu as toi pu vivre
qu'est ce que tu nous dire hé hé bien
que l'échec c'est une chance c'est qu'on
avait était fausse route
parce qu'aujourd'hui et bien non
seulement j'ai un bonheur intense de
jouer et d'être une artiste comique sur
scène avec l'amour que j'ai pour l'art
et en plus on me demande maintenant
d'intervenir dans les conservatoires
mais alors là plus en train de faire de
la chaise en disant oui ton pouce gauche
la plus plus hélas le deuxième là n'ont
encore pas travailler pendant la semaine
non là je vais dans les conservatoires
et je vais faire du clown avec les
musiciens pour les aider à respirer
autrement la musique
je pense qu'ils en avaient besoin voilà
[Applaudissements]
j'ai encore envie de profiter de ta
présence on a une heure on a une joueuse
d'heure est ce que vous voudriez un
autre morceau classique quelque chose de
très classique tu sais falloir à quelque
chose de très connu je peux faire le
canon de pachelbel non pas celle belle à
la part sophie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
procession à l'eau moi je préfère des
trucs plus enlevé un bébé coup quand
[Musique]
tout août salle itude amer ma vie est un
enfer fini les cadres diatonique aux
câblo s'appelle nick comme une corne sûr
j'en prends le rer
j'ai un regard un républicain méthode
dénommé patrick quand décidé affoué
moubarak qui a déterminé le matou quant
au tout tout tout le moi je vois une
gueule l'appui de le groupe doit jeter
c'est seulement voilà un qui sait pas il
contient matt war une bobine du cliquet
regarde ironique hymne des du ce moi je
suis quelqu'un j'ai un grand lit à
baldaquin
or hautes décidé à jouer mon bac j'ai
déterminé à tout et le vin doux quand
tout autour
patrick dame là monsieur jacques jouet
classé qu'à jaune un peu la confusion
pour quelques petites variations cas
néobaroque himdi tu ne vois rock givors
joue moi ton pachoud baltes et aux
canaux de la fiba
moi je moi ton van basten hôtel a pris
feu
[Applaudissements]
et les top canon sophie l'artiste